le docteur rade plutôt optimiste il a vu
les ravisseurs il est maintenant syrie
un plan est en discussion mais ce soir
encore la prudence est de rigueur dans
cette affaire le dernier indice avant
les élections le chômage est en légère
baisse -0 4% pour le mois de février
la victoire du oui à l'otan en espagne
c'est un succès personnel de première
grandeur pour le chef du gouvernement
espagnol felipe gonzalez
le plus grand musée des sciences et les
techniques du monde inauguré cet
après-midi à la villette cent cinquante
mille mètres carrés dans lesquelles la
science et l'industrie vont à la
rencontre du public
madame monsieur bonsoir toujours latente
à beyrouth la tente mais aussi une
certaine détente le docteur rade
interrompu ce matin ses négociations
avec les ravisseurs qui détiennent
toujours les otages français
c'est apparemment à la fin de la
première phase des discussions avec une
indication une indication de l'émissaire
français
un accord de principe est en voie
d'élaboration mais il reste encore à
régler les détails des détails qui
semblent importants une note optimiste
donc ce soir même si les inconnues
demeurent très nombreuses
nous allons revoir point par point
l'état de la négociation mais d'abord le
film de cette journée à beyrouth avec
notre envoyé spécial
ces pierres servent elles sont disons
encourageantes
elle ya deux choses différentes et
dessous toutes concordantes
nos coeurs à savoir aujourd'hui qu'il
faut être sur la bonne voie
les conditions posées par les réviseurs
sont virtuellement rennie il reste à les
réaliser
ces dernières 48 heures de doctorat de
la navette autres beyrouth beaulieu
c'est des tomates pour mettre au point
les modalités pratiques et garantit des
effets la décision de libérer qu'il
tentait feu a été prise
son sort des paliers à la sphère de
bagdad ditto ici des solutions que les
affaires pourraient être pourtant kokuvi
corde
ce qui veut dire que j'ai brouchoud et
ses coéquipiers devraient être libérés
au plus tard lorsqu'elle
craquez auront quitté bagdad et or ont
été reconnus par ceux qui les réclament
terceira antennes de beyrouth
vous l'avez entendu optimisme donc
optimisme mesuré sur place mais il faut
rester très prudent l'expérience dans
cette affaire nous l'a appris à de
nombreuses reprises en tout cas il
apparaît à peu près certain ce soir que
le docteur rade à négocier sur deux
points au moins la libération des 12
opposants irakiens expulsés par paris et
le sort du commando qui avait tenté
d'assassiner le premier ministre iranien
à paris le premier ministre chapour
bakhtiar le premier point est acquis ce
soir mais le deuxième reste à régler
daniel leconte la remise de de nos
frères irakiens aux autorités irakiennes
alors que la france savait qu'ils
étaient des opposants régime et qu'il
serait exécuté en irak est un défi
dangereux au sentiment de tous les
musulmans
ceci constitue une complicité de crimes
c'est dans ce communiqué annonçant la
mort de michel seurat et publie il y a
une semaine à beyrouth que le djihad
islamique évoqué pour la première fois
la question des deux irakiens expulsés
par paris depuis dans chaque communiqué
publié par la suite leur libération est
devenue la plus urgente des
revendications des ravisseurs
c'est donc maintenant chose faite la
libération d'amanda phase i et d'hassan
géraldine n'est plus qu'une question de
jours sinon d'heures saddam hussein le
président irakien en effet gracié les
deux expulsés fils sont autorisés s'ils
le veulent à retourner en france
un préalable capital pesant sur la
négociation vient donc d'être relevé
reste maintenant
l'autre revendication des ravisseurs
elle concerne la libération de cinq
membres d'un commando communiste ces
cinq hommes avaient tenté d'assassiner
l'ancien premier ministre iranien
chapour bakhtiar
c'était en juillet 1981 à neuilly au
cours de la fusillade deux personnes
devaient trouver la mort
arrêté sur le champ quatre d'entre eux
dont le chef du commando anis naccache
été condamné à la réclusion à perpétuité
le cinquième à 20 ans rien juridiquement
ne permet de les libérer dans les
prochains jours
les cinq hommes n'ont accompli que six
ans de prison or la peine minimum qu'ils
doivent obligatoirement purgé de 15,1
pour les en 15 ans pour les uns dix ans
pour
hot on est donc bien loin du compte
reste donc une seule solution pour
répondre aux ravisseurs la grâce
présidentielle
et puis et puis il ya cette phrase
justement hand anis naccache le chef du
commando qui a tenté d'assassiner et
chapour bakhtiar c'est un appel un
véritable appel lancé aux ravisseurs
vous devez rassurer toutes les familles
des otages c'est très précisément ce que
dit le chef du commando dans un
télégramme adressé vendredi à son avocat
un message qui est plus directement
destiné à ce qu'il appelle ses frères
c'est à dire les chiites iraniens un
texte qu interprète matin son avocat
maître contacter roger tout à l'heure
par thierry calmette de demande d'une
part de ne pas répondre aux déclarations
qu'il estime provocatrice de monsieur
fabius de la part de ses frères je pars
de rassurer la famille de tous les
otages sans exception sans exception
j'imagine que ça veut dire que il faut
que l'opinion publique française sache
tout moi je peux pas vous en dire plus
parce que je n'en sais pas plus il faut
maintenant que nous attendions la
réponse en quelque sorte à cette demande
à ses demandes
est ce que ces télégrammes diffusés à la
presse pourrait être un signal au
contraire vers le vers les ravisseurs
moi je le prends comme tel et c'est pour
ça que j'estime nécessaire est de mon
devoir de le faire connaître à la presse
c'est à dire que je pense que c'est de
la part de monsieur nakache qui
incontestablement semble avoir un rôle
central dans l'ensemble cette affaire
j'ai pensé que c'était une demande de sa
part de clarification j'ai pensé qu'au
moment où beaucoup de choses sont agités
et confuse
cette demande de clarification de son
importance où on a quand même la
pression ce soir que le chef du commando
attendent également une décision des
autorités françaises sur son sort et sur
celui de ses camarades qui sont donc
emprisonné en france mais impossible
d'en savoir plus pour le moment
et puis à paris monseigneur lustiger a
célébré une messe tout à l'heure à la
demande de la famille de michel seurat
dont l'exécution dont l'assassinât a été
annoncée par les ravisseurs l'archevêque
de paris a voulu associer tous les
otages à ses préoccupations et à ses
prières
ce sont des hommes de paix qui sont
allés dans un pays en guerre
ce sont des hommes qui aiment cette
région qui ont voulu rendre témoignage
si ces otages nous apparaissent comme
des victimes particulièrement
scandaleuse à la conscience c'est qu'ils
sont le signe que il n'y a plus de loi
le terrorisme
sous toutes ses formes comme le pape l'a
rappelé est ce qu'il faut proscrire
absolument
faute de quoi les états eux mêmes ne
sont plus dignes du droit qui veulent
promouvoir le tour de l'actualité nous
emmène maintenant en espagne où contre
toute attente et contre tous les
sondages le oui l'a emporté au soir du
référendum sur le maintien de l'espagne
où sein de l'otan de l'alliance
atlantique c'est une véritable surprise
mais c'est aussi un très beau succès
pour le premier ministre felipe gonzalez
qui est parvenu en quelques jours à
faire en quelque sorte basculer
l'opinion dans le sens qui lui convenait
sur place à madrid
bruno allemands mardi soir clôture de la
campagne
felipe gonzalez jette pis son capital de
sympathie dans le plateau du hui
hier soir le oui l'emportent sans
discussion ce matin felipe à la une le
succès du oui c'est lui
pour gagner il devait premièrement
contrebalancer les effets conjugués de
la version naturelle des espagnols pour
le militarisme et les yankees comme on
les appelle ici deux limiter les effets
de l'abstention prôné par le parti
conservateur pourtant favorable à l'otan
et surtout troisièmement limiter au
minimum les effets de son propre
changement de camp d'anti autant felipe
gonzalez est devenu en quatre ans un
partisan déclaré de l'atlantisme la
contrepartie le revers de la médaille
c'est le prix de cette volte face sur un
thème qui tient tellement à coeur aux
espagnols le premier ministre les avait
adjuré à voir la fin de la campagne de
se prononcer hier sur le fond
c'est-à-dire sur le maintien ou non de
l'espagne dans l'alliance atlantique et
de réserver tout vote de sanctions pour
les élections législatives
il a apparemment été entendu et rendez
vous est pris pour octobre prochain
l'enjeu ce sera la majorité dont dispose
au parlement le parti de l'homme
politique le plus populaire d'espagne
dans l' enquête sur le meurtre d'olof
palme
un homme a suédois vient d'être arrêté
par la police de stockholm ce n'est pour
le moment qu'un suspect on lui reproche
surtout apparemment de s'être trouvé sur
les lieux du crime le soir de
l'assassinât
après la baisse de l'inflation rendue
publique hier une baisse historiquement
à 0 2% voici le dernier indice avant les
élections c'est le chiffre du chômage
pour le mois de février il vient d'être
publié ils annoncent une légère baisse
pour le mois dernier justement -0 4%
ce sont maintenant les explications et
les commentaires de gérard morin sur ce
chiffre
la stabilisation se confirme le chômage
était au sommet en janvier 85 puis
diminution légère petit poucet le mois
dernier et nous revoilà avec deux
millions trois cent soixante sept mille
600 demandeurs d'emploi même niveau
qu'en octobre 85 et qu'en octobre 84
la raison de ce léger mieux c'est que la
dégradation de l'activité économique
semble stoppée moins de licenciements
économiques mois de chômage par
elle davantage d'offres d'emploi
disponibles cela dit les entrées en
stage de formation augmenté mais pas
tellement les embauches dans les
entreprises
le chômage n'est pas vaincu ce sera
encore un gros point noir dans les mois
à venir et ce drame durant longtemps
lorsqu'il frappe quelqu'un en moyenne 3
129 jours
il reste que ces chiffres des demandeurs
d'emploi en moins nombreux à la fin
février
c'est une assez bonne nouvelle pour le
gouvernement à deux jours des élections
c'est pourquoi le ministre du travail
s'est dépêché de les publier
effectivement les indices économiques et
sociaux qui auront figurer en bonne
place dans la campagne électorale qu'ils
aient été donc apprécié ou contester
cela nous amène directement à notre page
spéciale maintenant une page spéciale
consacrée comme chaque soir au scrutin
de dimanche
attention il ne reste plus que deux
jours
et pour commencer une question quoi la
marque concerne françois mitterrand
partira partira pas prêt d après le
monde d'hier je crois que le microcosme
parisien ne parlait que de ça
aujourd'hui absolument la rumeur court
toujours
toujours pas démentie toujours pas
confirmé et elle a pour effet
d'alimenter le jeu politique à la mode
un jeu en forme de devinette
si l'opposition gagne qui ira à matignon
le nom le plus souvent cité celui de
jacques chirac mais la réapparition de
jacques chaban delmas intrigue bien sûr
il n'est pas candidat officiellement
mais il tient à montrer qu'il est
toujours en forme
rachid arhab et yves barbe sont allés à
bordeaux
arrivé à bordeaux de jacques chaban
delmas ancien premier ministre ancien
président de l'assemblée nationale
député maire de bordeaux président du
conseil régional d'aquitaine avec une
telle carte de visite
chaban at il encore besoin de faire
campagne à 71 ans
c'est lui que l'opposition a choisi pour
mener de front la liste des législatives
et celles des régionales au pas de
course bien sûr il y a deux ans chaban
avait été élu à la tête du conseil
régional d'aquitaine ce grâce au
ralliement secret de deux élus de gauche
la cohabitation avait elle commencé à
bordeaux tout à fait nouvelle société
son projet politique nationale n'a donc
pas changé même si chaban se dit moins
intéressé par matignon que par le
conseil régional d'aquitaine
si j'ai la possibilité d'établir encore
deux budgets c'est les 87 8 88 alors
vraiment la région à l'aquitaine sera
lancée pour longtemps dans la bonne
direction
face à chaban le ps girondin joue la
carte jeune
une campagne de fête et de banquets
menée par catherine lalumière
ça va ou plutôt ça va mieux
les socialistes espèrent obtenir quatre
sièges contre cinq à l'opposition mais
tout n'a pas été sans mal
l'élaboration de la liste ps a été un
véritable casse tête
une lutte serrée entre les différents
courants socialistes qui quel est le
département qui n'a pas eu quelques
difficultés à établir la liste parce que
le scrutin proportionnel nécessite que
l'on soit bien placé sur la liste pour
avoir des chances d'être élu sur les
docks de bordeaux les communistes de
gironde ne nie plus leur recul tous les
permanents été renouvelée en trois ans
mais le discours n'a pas changé
michel perret tête de liste communiste
réinvente même la vieille recette blanc
bonnet et bonnet blanc à la sauce
cohabitation chaban delmas mitterrand
on était dans le même parti et les
desserts si je ne trompe pas ils ont été
ensemble dans beaucoup de ministères et
lorsque le président de la république
est venu à bordeaux
l'un et l'autre ont évoqué leur chemin
qu'ils se sont croisés décroisée
recroiser à l'extrême-droite divorce
total
le front national est concurrencée par
une liste sur laquelle se trouve madame
le pen en instance de divorce
elle a rejoint les dissidents du front
d'opposition nationale les deux listes
d'extrême droite ne s'en voit pas de
fleurs pour s'accuser mutuellement
d'être noyautés par le maire de bordeaux
avec la complicité du ps
vous avez dit cohabitation après cette
bataille des girondins nous reprenons
nous terminons notre série sur les
grands thèmes économiques de la campagne
vu par les co leaders politiques alors
on a vu tour à tour laurent fabius
valéry giscard d'estaing et georges
marchais hier ce soir donc c'est jacques
chirac pour l'erp et oui nous avons
réalisé cette série d'interviews pour
répondre aux lettres et aux voeux des
téléspectateurs qui souhaitent connaître
la politique économique des différents
partis et plus précisément les mesures
envisagées pour lutter contre le chômage
ce soir donc jacques chirac à qui jean
louis le cn a demandé de définir
l'esprit de la plateforme rpr udf
écoutons le
ce qu'il faut c'est créer des emplois
créés les emplois c'est chez l'artisan
chez le commerçant
chez l'industriel sur le professionnel
libéral que c'est possible mais pour
cela il faut diminuer les charges et les
complaintes sur ces entreprises c'est à
dire les impôts les taxes les
cotisations ça suppose une politique de
réduction des dépenses publiques
il faut également diminuer toutes ces
réglementations qui paralyse le contrôle
des prix des changes le contrôle des
marges
toutes ces autorisations ses effets de
seuil qui décourage il faut également
que les travailleurs se sont appelés à
faire un effort et pour cela il faut
diminuer aussi les charges qui pèsent
sur eux et leurs données par une
politique de participation plus active
le sentiment que l'entreprise est un
lieu où ils peuvent participer et
s'épanouir davantage par la flexibilité
mieux adapter leur travail à leur mode
test pour le chômage les jeunes l'étude
voulait maintenant pour le chômage des
jeunes qui est évidemment l'essentiel de
nos préoccupations
il faut créer un système de contrats
emploi formation ouvert non seulement à
l'administration comme l'étude mais à
l'ensemble des activités qui comporte
une partie travail et une partie
formation la partie travail est en payer
non pas sur noise mans comme dans les
tubes en dessous du smic mais au smic et
dont les charges sociales soit pour tout
ou partie prise en charge par l'état de
façon à inciter ces entrepreneurs que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure à s'engager
dans la voie du recrutement du vrac
si la confiance est rétablie si les
liberté d'action le goût du risque et le
sens de l'effort reviennent en raison de
cette de ce pouce
berthe et donc on peut effectivement
compte tenu de la conjoncture
internationale qui s'améliore je ne
dirais pas voir le bout du tunnel car
sept pas pellicule mais améliorer la
citation la situation essentiellement de
l'emploi ce qui est la plus haute ce que
l'on pourra gagner de la baisse du
dollar et de la baisse du pétrole qui ne
présente pas que des avantages par
ailleurs il faut le savoir devrait être
affectée à la réduction des charges qui
paralyse actuellement notre collègue
voilà c'est donc la fenêtre série tous
les candidats politiques y sont passés
mais les élections à la campagne
électorale ce n'est pas seulement les
grandes idées c'est aussi le terrain le
local oui et les français attachent
quelquefois ces querelles de clochers
beaucoup plus d'importance qu'aux débat
sur les institutions
ils n'ont pas forcément tort elle porte
en effet souvent sur leur vie
quotidienne
c'est le cas dans l'allier où il
n'existe pas de sa mue quatre villes se
disputent l'attribution de ce service
médical d'urgence alin valentigney noël
alexandre ont eu l'idée de réunir les
maires de ces quatre sites et ils ont
tous une étiquette politique différente
l'équilibré respecter l or ont demandé
de plaider leur dossier pour ne léser
personne
notre équipe a choisi le terrain le plus
neutre possible
monaco no m
messieurs pour le samu faites vos jeux
la parole est à hector rolland maire rpr
de lula je considère que le samu dans le
cas où il ne s'est pas installé à
moulins ce serait un non sens total
pourquoi moulin parce que c'est la ville
préfectorale pour casse c'est là que se
sont établis les services indispensables
au bon fonctionnement de sa vue en plus
nous avons l'air d'atterrissage tout
préparé tellement le meilleur du
département les hélicoptères il est tout
à fait naturel que le chat bus sera
installé à moulins merci nous écoutons
maintenant monsieur jacques milliez
maire ps de cusset ou et qui s'est
intéressé dans le cadre du syndicat
intercommunal de l'agglomération de
vichy et je peux dire que dans l'allier
il ya de grands axes le val de cher le
val d'allier vichy avec l'agglomération
du compte environ 70000 habitants et ses
structures hospitalières
non loin du chu de clermont ferrand est
un bon secteur géographique et un bon
secteur d'intervention pour les urgences
accidents graves de la route
on vous remercie la parole est à pierre
golbert maire pc de morceaux il y a
cette raison qu'ils font que montluçon
doit être la ville choisie premièrement
nous avons un smur dont la qualité n'est
contesté par personne avec une équipe de
médecins soudée nous avons un bloc
opératoire ultramoderne un scanner qui
est installée actuellement nous avons
une piste délistage et sixièmement le
seul corps de sapeurs pompiers
professionnels et enfin nous sommes au
bord de l'autoroute qui traverse le
département en deux dont comme chacun le
reconnaît maintenant c'est à montluçon
que doit s'installer le samu dans
l'intérêt de tous les bourbonnais merci
enfin pour terminer la parole est à
monsieur jacques lacaze maire udf pr2i
je suis croupier au grand casino de
vichy chargé de me signaler l'absence de
monsieur jacques la cadre il a déclaré
antenne 2 qui ne jugeait pas utile de se
déplacer etc à propos du samu il devait
sept en tout cas évident pour lui
revenir logiquement à vichy
les jeux sont faits l'allier aura enfin
son samu 1 pour les trois villes mais
peut-être même un parent ville réponse
dans les jours qui viennent
un bel exemple en tout cas de
divergences politiques qui peut aboutir
à une cohabitation départementale
efficace une cathédrale une cathédrale
pour la science et l'industrie s'est
ouverte aujourd'hui à paris c'est la
fameuse cité des sciences et les
techniques de la villette
c'est le plus grand musée du genre
jamais construit au monde ils coûtent
cher 4 milliards et demi de francs pour
un projet les vrais considérable qui
occupent qui occupe 150 mille mètres
carrés françois mitterrand inaugurait
tout à l'heure alors que les travaux
viennent tout juste tout juste de se
terminer
en tout cas pour la première tranche
l'ouverture officielle c'est pour demain
c'est alors que le public pourra
investir la cité ce sera sans doute
qu'une prise de contact vous le voyez
puisqu'il faut des jours des jours
entiers pour découvrir toutes les
richesses de ce musée du 21ème siècle
alors jacques violet françois granier
non on avance visiter pour vous c'est
une avant première la science se
reflétant dans le futur la géode cette
boule d'acier poli de 36 mètres de
diamètre qui abrite déjà une salle de
cinéma domine la cité des sciences
un bâtiment gigantesque cent cinquante
mille mètres carrés de marbre gris de
poutrelles d'acier de façade de verre
270 mètres de long 110 de large et 42
aux deux fois et demie beaubourg
mais le jour de son inauguration le
temple des sciences est encore un
immense chantier impression de
gigantisme également à l'intérieur
dans le grand hall au centre du bâtiment
des escaliers roulants escalade 12
mètres de hauteur et permettent
d'accéder aux expositions permanentes
conçu pour tous les publics de 3 83 ans
on entre ici pour s'informer comprendre
manipuler participer au maximum
premier secteur le fond des mers et les
étoiles avec des maquettes grandeur
nature le sous marin français le nautile
et le troisième étage de la fusée ariane
des satellites des modules du
laboratoire spatial permettront de
prendre la vraie mesure des engins de
l'espace et comprendre la pesanteur sous
l'oeil d'un astronaute dans son fauteuil
volant dans la section mathématiques
l'audiovisuel associées à l'informatique
pour comprendre la force de coriolis le
théorème de pythagore où les lois de la
physique expliqué de façon attractive
dans le monde des sons un spectrographe
vous permettra de voir la trace de votre
voix sur un écran en couleur
les enfants n'ont pas été oubliés pour
eux l'un vante orium où ils pourront
regarder vivre les fourmis sous la terre
et les poissons dans les aquariums
reste une question combien coûte cette
vulgarisation scientifique tous azimuts
réponse quatre milliards et demi pour la
construction du bâtiment 600 millions de
francs pour le fonctionnement en 86
certains parlent de gouffre financier la
ville est en a connu d'autres autant des
abattoirs un seul regret pour tous
aujourd'hui seulement un bon tiers des
activités sera ouvert au public le reste
comme le planétarium ouvrira dans le
courant de l'été
la chasse à la comète c'est pour ce soir
cette nuit vers 1h du matin la sonde
européenne giotto on aura la comète de
halley à quelques deux cent cinquante
mille kilomètres heures vous pourrez
suivre en direct sur antenne 2 jotzo
passera alors à 500 km 5 km seulement de
la fameuse comète c'est une opération
gigantesque dirigé depuis darmstadt en
allemagne fédérale où l'on vit les
derniers boulons si l'on peut dire
patrick esther et bien bernard tout se
présente bien dans classe au centre
opérationnel de l'agencé spatiale
européenne
la dernière correction de trajectoire
d'avoir vient d'avoir lieu avec succès
actuellement la sonde de giotto et à un
million deux cent trente-quatre mille
lits 112 km de son point de rencontre
avec la comète
ce chiffre il est croît très rapidement
d'aller voir puisque sept ans j'ai
interpellé peur fonceuse lavezzi à 250
mille kilomètres à l'heure à travers le
viscos mik la rencontre aura donc lieu
cette nuit à une heure et deux minutes
je te passera alors à 500 km de la
comète de halley il n'a dû racheter pas
certain que cette sonde puisse survivre
violente projection de poussière de gas
emg disparu noyau jusqu'à ce jour
personne n'y ait aucun instrument
scientifique n'a pu photographier ou
voir le noyau d'une comète
alors on peut dire que cette comète qui
passe le chouchou de 16 ans pour la
plupart d'entre nous c'est l'unique
occasion ce soit en direction n 2 de la
voir de ses propres yeux
on dirait un fabuleux voyage qui se
déroule à 145 millions de km de la terre
un formidable cours de travaux pratiques
qui a pour objet l'univers et je crois
que même si demain les collégiens les
lycéens et leurs professeurs arrivent
avec des allumettes dans l'est
pour lui faire un atelier ouvert je
crois que cette nuit blanche qu'on leur
propose de passer dans le noir du cosmos
en vaut vraiment la peine
oui l'espace l'espace où l'on se
bouscule puisque les soviétiques
viennent de lancer à nouveau vaisseau
habité par deux cosmonautes fait sans
précédent la télévision soviétique
l'annoncé par avance et a même montré
des images du lancement les voici
décidément quelque chose a changé à
moscou les deux cosmonautes sont en
chemin pour occuper une nouvelle station
orbitale lancé le 20 février dernier
c'est un projet de très grande envergure
puisque cette station est prévue pour
des vols de longue durée et pour une
occupation permanente je devrais être en
quelque sorte la station de base des
futurs complexes orbitaux tels que les
conçoivent les soviétiques
une sorte de jeu de lego que l'on peut
agrandir à volonté avec des modules
expédié depuis la terre une question
maintenant une question avez vous la
gueule de l'emploi drôle de question
pensez-vous d'aphatie drôle puisque une
nouvelle discipline la morphopsychologie
permettent en principe d'analyser le
caractère d'un individu par la simple
observation de son visage
alors c'est une technique mise au point
par le docteur louis corman est
aujourd'hui bien l'utilisent dans
certains cabinets de recrutement voici
le reportage que viennent de nous
envoyer
patrick boitet et jean louis goût sert
montrer maintenant des exemples connus
de gens célèbres un cours de
morphopsychologie chez et gore la
première entreprise française de
recrutement ces chasseurs de têtes
s'entraîne à comprendre le caractère
d'un individu à partir de son visage
s'était rétracté de front
oui avec une expansion cérébrales
importantes
voilà mais très grand très grand
harmonie des visages correspond en
général et l'harmonie du caractère ce
que nous essayons de faire c'est de
rationaliser nos intuitions et je dirais
de rationaliser vos intuitions qu'elle
essaie régulièrement les
morphopsychologue tiennent des
conférences dans les grandes villes de
france dans le public les responsables
du personnel apprennent comment choisir
leurs collaborateurs selon l'importance
de leur mâchoire où l'écartement de
leurs yeux il n'existe pas de portrait
robot pour une fonction donné par contre
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que dans des
fonctions il devait avoir des
caractéristiques très précises je vous
donnais par exemple deux exemples il est
bon qu'un commercial quelque part il y
ait deux à peu du dilate et que quelque
part le mode les soirs on un directeur
d'usiné me paraît important qu'il est
une base instinctive suffisante pour
remplir à ses obligations de
commandement et d'autorité
quelque chose qui m'a
la morphopsychologie chez et gore sert
de techniques d'appoint aux entretiens
et aux tests graphologique
mais elle est parfois directement
utilisés pour la sélection des candidats
ce qui révolte certains professionnels
d'abord parce que la morphopsychologie a
tendance à définir des normes et ce au
moins autant que la graphologie
or nous ne cherchons pas des gens
normaux nous ne cherchons pas les
encéphalogramme plat
on sait très bien qu'un certain nombre
de gens qui ont notoirement réussi
aurait probablement été éliminés dans le
cadre par exemple d'un truc goff logique
ou d'un tri morphopsychologie et si
l'amour en psychologie rentrer dans la
vie de tous les jours à ce serait
drôlement intéressant parce que - chaque
os auraient acquis l'île à faire et ça a
évité de se tromper ou sur le choix du
conjoint ou ou sur le choix de ses amis
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
personne
c'est quelqu'un de remarquablement
équilibré qui a de très bons contacts et
qui est fait pour la communication et
pour les relations et bien à ce poste
alors oui il est très bien ce poste mais
il aurait pu faire n'importe quoi sauf
peut-être en coureur de champion pour ça
que petite gueule quoi à part manger
moins de chance d'être engagé à la
télévision après tout seul la gueule de
l'emploi ce sera en tout cas l'un des
sujets abordés par le magazine d'antenne
2 à 22h10 un magazine très fournie
puisque vous y verrez également un
étonnant reportage sur l'iran et sur les
recherches que les hommes de khomeiny
mène à l'ambassade des états unis
c'est là où furent détenus les otages
américains peu de chose en sport cette
information tout faux il s'agit de
formule 1 philippe streiff signe chez
tyrrell pour la saison 86 il rejoint
ainsi martin brundle et puis l'arrivée
du quarter 2 3 15 et 6 rapports dans là
pour 5 francs 124 1880 safran et dans un
ordre différent toujours pour 5 francs
1694 francs 50 avant de prendre
connaissance de la météo voici des
nouvelles de la télévision générale de
notre chaîne en particulier puisque nous
connaissons ce soir les résultats du
sondage du centre d'études des supports
de publicité c'est ce que nous appelons
le cs le csp il nous donne en quelque
sorte la photographie de l'audience pour
une période donnée en l'occurrence celle
qui court du 7 janvier au 5 février
dernier avec d'abord un constat jamais
les français n'ont autant regarder la
télévision 35 millions six cent trente
cinq mille personnes ont regardé au
moins une fois par jour
dans ce contexte antenne 2 enregistre la
plus forte progression des télévisions
depuis la dernière vague de c2c respect
c'était à l'automne 85 pour la première
fois nous franchissons la barre des 26
millions de téléspectateurs c'est la
plus forte audience de notre maison
depuis sa création en 1975 ce résultat
est en grande partie due l'accueil très
positif que vous avez réservé à nos
soirées
et puis un dernier un dernier chiffre
avec deux heures d'écouté par
téléspectateurs et par jour antenne 2 et
la télévision la plus regardée en france
merci donc pour votre fidélité et pour
votre confiance et maintenant rapidement
la météo avec leurs embouts si très vite
avoue de météo très rapide où après vous
avoir dit que demain il y aura des
brouillards sur une grille
partis du pays on va tout de suite
regardé la photo satellite avec
l'arrivée d'une nouvelle perturbation
qui demain sera évidemment sur l'ouest
du pays ça nous donne de nouveaux nuages
sur l'ouest
alors on regarde la carte du temps prévu
pour demain voilà avec sur toute la
bretagne et la normandie un ciel couvert
de la pluie sur le reste du pays je
faisais de la brume et débrouillard mais
un temps qui deviendra beau dans la
journée sauf sur le roussillon les
pluies continueront et saufs sur
l'accord suit lui rend encore quelques
orages côté température c'est le statu
quo elles sont immobiles de 5 à 12
degrés sur la moitié nord avec un 8
degrés à paris et deux sets mais jusqu'à
15 degrés sur la moitié sud 15 2
biarritz à nice tout ça c'est tout à
fait parfait notre agenda pour terminer
demain c'est vendredi 14 mars le soleil
se lèvera à 7h02 se couchera à 18h52 ce
qui nous fera trois minutes de soleil en
plus c'est la sainte mathilde alors
bonne fête mathilda je vous rappelle la
formation saillantes de ce journal à
certaines optimisme à un optimisme
mesuré se dégage à beyrouth après les
négociations menées par le docteur rade
il a vu les ravisseurs avant de
retourner en syrie et un plan est
actuellement en discussion misme donc il
faut demeurer ce soir encore très
prudents si d'autres développements se
produisent dans les heures qui viennent
nous donner l'explication de
commentaires dans notre dernier journal
c'est avec bernard pradines au aux
environs de 22 heures 55 bonsoir
admirateurs